foreign
[Music]
you might have heard of vertex AI but
what is it exactly well don't worry we
have all the details so give us two
minutes and we'll give you a quick
rundown of what it is and how to use it
so let's get to it
vertex AI is an end-to-end ml platform
that helps both developers and data
scientists accelerate the delivery of ml
models and applications to production
vertex AI enables more people to
innovate with ML with low code tools and
advanced capabilities for custom
development all on fully managed
infrastructure
let's dive into the features and
benefits of vertex AI jumpstart neml
project with access to a variety of
model types and sizes in the model
Garden you can choose the right model
for your use case ml expertise and
budget with access to task specific apis
in automl Foundation models from Google
research and a variety of models from
our open source and third-party partners
use the model directly as an API with
client libraries in several different
languages tune the model in the
generative AI Studio or deploy the model
directly to a data science notebook in
vertex AI build the next generation of
applications faster with tools that help
both application developers and data
scientists tune and deploy large models
generative AI Studio provides a wide
range of capabilities that include a
chat interface prompt design prompt
tuning and even the ability to fine-tune
model weights want to build a custom
model vertex ai's ml platform helps
teams track custom model development and
deployment from feature engineering to
model training to low latency inference
all with Enterprise security data
governance and availability once models
are deployed end-to-end ml Ops
capabilities make it easy to automate
govern and monitor ml workflows reducing
the work needed to maintain Mall
performance at scale and enabling teams
to move faster
we can't wait to see what you build with
vertex AI whether you're a developer
looking to add AI to your application or
a data scientist wanting to build and
scale custom ml in production vertex AI
has the tools that you need to learn
more check out the vertex AI homepage
and thanks for listening today
[Music]